estamos nuevamente con ustedes para
actualizar la información en materia
económica de américa latina y el resto
del mundo junto a daniela blandón por
supuesto daniela comenzamos con noticias
de américa latina' del sur del
continente americano vamos a chile
porque esta semana se va a discutir un
nuevo retiro de pensiones así de
santiago muy buenas noches mire la
iniciativa que busca que los ciudadanos
puedan retirar otro 10% de sus ahorros
pensionales será enviada esta semana al
pleno de la cámara de diputados y de ahí
va a pasar al senado para su votación
definitiva este sería el tercer retiro
anticipado de un 10 por ciento de estos
fondos en menos de un año en julio se
aprobó el primero del que se
beneficiaron unas diez cuatro millones
de personas o sea un 95 por ciento de
los 11 millones de afiliados en
diciembre se avaló otro retiro del que
disfrutaron 76 millones de ciudadanos en
ambos casos santiago cada ahorrador
recibió alrededor de dos mil dólares y a
la fecha se han desembolsado más de 36
mil millones de dólares el gobierno que
no estuvo de acuerdo con el primer
retiro pero sí con el segundo
a veces no lo apoya aunque si lo hacen
varios parlamentarios oficialistas
pasamos de chile a su vecina argentina
donde hubo protestas contra el femenino
el fondo monetario internacional pues de
un grupo de manifestantes que volvió a
las calles de buenos aires en momentos
en que el gobierno de alberto fernández
avanza en las negociaciones con este
organismo para reestructurar una
millonaria deuda
veamos santiago este país le debe 44 mil
millones de dólares al fondo monetario
internacional y enfrenta también un
vencimiento de 2.400 millones de dólares
con el club de parís precisamente el
ministro de economía martín guzmán está
de gira por europa discutiendo con los
diferentes gobiernos sobre estas deudas
los manifestantes alegan que cualquier
dólar que vaya a usarse en el pago de
estas obligaciones debe ir a enfrentar
la grave situación económica que vive el
país sobre todo ahora después de la
pandemia abandonamos a ni la américa
latina' vamos ahora a siria el
presidente del gobierno le pidió al
gobernador del banco central que sucedió
pues santiago estamos hablando de
hacemos cárcel quiero
el cargo desde finales de 2018 su
destitución por el presidente bachar al
asad se da en medio de una grave
depreciación de la moneda local si a
comienzos del conflicto sirio en 2011 un
dólar estadounidense valía 47 libras
sirias hoy diez años después santiago
cuesta cuatro mil 600 libras en el
mercado ilegal
estos son cien veces más y si lo medimos
en términos de salarios mínimos hoy
equivale a 29 dólares y en ese entonces
era casi dos mil dólares así que calcule
usted la proporción el desploma de la
moneda ha sumido a más sirios en la
pobreza las naciones unidas estiman que
ocho de cada diez viven por debajo de la
línea de pobreza además el problema no
sólo afecta a siria sino también a sus
vecinos turquía o líbano entre otros
vamos ahora a europa hay una iniciativa
bastante interesante que se está
discutiendo con varios países que están
comprometiéndose a no financiar
proyectos petroleros en el extranjero
verdad santiago son siete países y les
voy a decir cuáles son alemania francia
reino unido españa países bajos suecia y
dinamarca
estos forman parte de una coalición que
llamaron exportó finance for future que
este miércoles va a firmar un compromiso
para dejar de dar ayuda pública a esta
clase de proyectos como una contribución
contra la crisis climática hoy más del
35 por ciento de los créditos públicos
de los países de la ocde que también se
conoce como el club de países ricos va
dirigido a proyectos de combustibles
fósiles estos países también han
implementado sus propias estrategias
hablemos por ejemplo de españa' que
aprobó hace unos días una ley de cambio
climático que establece que desde 2040
va a quedar prohibida la venta de
vehículos con motores de combustión
interna a nivel que nos dice en los
indicadores de esta jornada wall street'
del cerro mixto aunque tuvo un nuevo
récord en el índice standard en pues en
una jornada marcada por el repunte de la
inflación este mismo dato movió en
terrenos dispares a las bolsas de europa
en donde también hay preocupación sobre
la vacuna de johnson y johnson y en
américa latina' segunda subida
consecutiva en la bolsa de sao paulo y
para cerrar como siempre la cifra del
día cuales tome nota 1,4 billones de
dólar
estas son las pérdidas anuales que
genera el consumo de tabaco por los
gastos sanitarios y ocasiona de acuerdo
con la organización mundial de la salud
los impuestos al tabaco en 2018 se
elevaron a 360 mil millones de dólares o
sea lo que acercó en impuestos apenas es
una cuarta parte de lo que se gasta en
salud otro motivo más para dejar de
fumar daniela muchísimas gracias por
esta crónica tan completa hasta aquí la
información económica en france 24 los
invitamos a seguir informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación
[Música]